we're back with a fox news alert one of
kamala harris's top advisors
communications director ashley attene
has announced she's stepping down from
her post or she was fired the news comes
as mere hours after vice president's
train wreck interview with abc with her
approval ratings in the gutter
worst of any vice president of all time
harris took some softball questions from
democrat george stephanopoulos this
morning where she looked to downplay the
reported tensions between her and the
president watch
vice presidents always face chatter
about their role in the relevance so you
don't feel misused or underused
no i don't i am very very excited about
the work that we have accomplished
not really sure what vice president
giggles is excited about because when
she was confronted about the sky-high
inflation in america we got this highly
edited response
this is all happening in the context of
two years of a pandemic it's one of the
highest priorities actually for the
president and for me and so we're
dealing with this issue in a number of
ways short term one of the issues is the
supply chain we're seeing a bottleneck
and we need to relieve that bottleneck
i wonder what her real answer was
because abc showed us a version with
four edits in just 15 seconds
i guess she didn't have one
now let's bring it into lara trump and
stephen miller all right laura i mean
she giggles
and then her answer was so atrocious
they had to edit it four times in 15
seconds
well i mean she has yet to give a good
interview i'm still waiting on that i
think we all are waiting on that she
touted by the way all the
accomplishments of the biden harris
administration don't forget again we
have to add the harrison because she's
played a very important role as she'll
tell you there
and i think a lot of people think well
gosh what have they accomplished if
anything but i take it a little bit
differently perhaps they actually jesse
are accomplishing the things that they
would like to see happen in america
after all it we'd be crazy at this point
to think that our open border was not
intentional that they are letting
millions of undocumented illegal
immigrants flow into america
if you look at our stance on the world
stage they want america to look weak
after all we just want to be a
homogenous group of countries we don't
want to be a superpower anymore that's
all part of the new world order they
want to kill capitalism they are killing
small businesses every single day and
then they want people to get used to
reliance on the government so continuing
to pay people to stay home from work
no incentives for people to get back out
there and find the jobs people even
stopped trying to do it at this point so
perhaps she's right maybe she got
something right in this interview maybe
they're accomplishing all their goals
here it's unfortunate they're all bad
for america and saki said she was okay
with high gas prices because that just
makes it easier for people to go green
steve miller wow i mean this is not good
you go to the biggest softball guy in
television george stephanopoulos
democrat hack for a cleanup job and she
botched it
yeah i mean there weren't even any
difficult follow-ups i mean all she had
to do to have a good interview was to
avoid awkwardly laughing and she
couldn't even do that and that's a
pretty low bar to hit
the only person in the country that is
pulling worse or the only politician
pulling worse than joe biden is kamala
harris that's a political crisis for
this administration it's like having the
titanic sink and finding out that your
lifeboats are all filled with holes i
mean it is truly a political catastrophe
because they have nowhere to go and i
will also add that as they're looking to
pass this build back better monstrosity
and twist arms in the house and
especially the senate
democrats have to know that with the
unpopularity of biden and harris they
are looking at a midterm wipeout if they
vote for this bill yeah huge thumping
right around the corner for that do you
think lara that
the joe people in the white house are
cutting kamala loose and throwing her
under the bus because they believe
kamala is the one that's dragging down
joe biden's numbers
well it's hard to know what's happening
in this white house jesse this is
probably the least transparent white
house we have seen in modern history you
don't get much information
at all from them so perhaps that's the
tactic but i mean i think that steven is
right this is a sinking ship they have
known it i mean the problem though with
kamala harris is they knew getting into
this how unpopular she was she dropped
out so early
during the democrat primaries because
she was polling so low then and then
they told us all well we're gonna choose
her based on how she looks so no one is
surprised about this maybe they think
that making her look worse makes joe
look better unfortunately it makes them
all look really bad and us as americans
look even worse yeah it speaks to joe
biden's poor instincts which if anybody
had followed politics for the last few
decades
we already knew we're bad steven lara
thank you guys hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else